Ukraine must brace for more Russian
attacks on energy facilities and be
prepared for persistent power blackouts
across the country that was the message
from President Vladimir zielinski in his
nightly addressed to the nation on
Sunday
one Energy company says the entire
country saw a 32 percent shortfall in
power supply on Monday
the mayor of Kiev Vitale kichko has
warned people in the capital to prepare
for a worst case scenario where Power
and Water is lost entirely
as of this evening's stabilization power
outages continue in Kiev and six regions
more than four and a half million
consumers without electricity most of
them are now in Kiva and the Kiev region
it's really difficult
I speak to Assad Bank who's in curvary
in central Ukraine so the blackouts that
we're talking about they're just they're
not just confined to Kiev are they what
is the latest Where You Are
well blackouts have been rolling across
the country in other regions as well but
all eyes are now are on the capital
after the mayor there said that people
should be prepared to leave the city in
the event of a complete blackout now
Vitalia Klitschko made the statement
urging people to buy Power Banks and
warm clothes in preparation of different
scenarios you told them not to be
pessimistic but they should be prepared
should leave the capital and go stay
with friends and relatives now as you
heard from the Ukrainian president there
president zielinski he said about 4.5
million people are without electricity
and again Iran Kiev and those regions
but also elsewhere as the Russians
continue to strike key infrastructure in
Ukraine now where we are incredible
Revisited uh bunkers yesterday the
administrations have set up in this city
to keep people warm and they say they're
setting up around 300 300 of those
they've got generators ready they've got
food and blankets uh just in case now
the temperature is already dropping last
night it was around -1 and expecting to
drop well below that later this week and
so you can imagine how difficult it is
for people now south of here in Hassan
that that fighting that offensive is
continuing there's been increased
artillery shelling taking place there
but her son and the region her son the
capital and the region were without
electricity now the ukrainians blame uh
the Russians they said that they damaged
some power lines and they administrator
there blamed the Russians said and I
quote they will do crazy things as
Ukraine pressures forward on this
offensive now the Russians are blaming
the ukrainians what they've said is that
the ukrainians damage the dam and the
infrastructure and they've been
evacuating people a move that a Russian
President Vladimir Putin has publicly
endorsed now the fear from the
ukrainians is that the Russians will
blow that damn now they've been saying
that for a while now what's given extra
impetus to this is that some cities and
towns surrounding that Dam the Russians
have told residents to leave by the 10th
of November and the ukrainians are
saying that they plan to blow it but
also at the same time the Ukrainian
authorities are saying that Russian
soldiers around 20 to 25 000 still
remain in her son that Regional capital
and some of them have changed into
civilian clothes taking a position in
apartments and up preparing for Street
battles uh when the ukrainians push
forward but realistically if and it is a
big if and it is speculation if the the
dam is blown it will flood the entire
area
it would reflect the entire area also
the Russian positions but it would give
a natural barrier between the Ukrainian
forces and the Russian forces thank you
for that as I'd beg in crevety